all right it looks like finally reality
is setting in
for seattle's oh summer of love
autonomous
chaz chop spaghetti potluck dinner zone
mayor jenny durkin
who's now begging for the city to
rebuild its police department
after a number of shootings over the
weekend but remember it was durkin
who was demonizing police all last
summer even boasted about the city's
chop zone that took the life of our
national treasures
we had the father of horus lorenzo
anderson jron
that was a heartbreaking interview yeah
he died in that summer of love zone
and we covered it on this program the
media mob no they ignored it
and you know just like they barely
covered this week the mugging of former
california senator barbara boxer in
oakland
and across the bay in san francisco
and i have thieves all over the place
broad daylight
ransacking you know pretty much every
store available more
recently a cvs as thefts continue to
plague that city because now they're not
arresting as long as you
don't steal a thousand dollars worth of
material
defund dismantle no bail doesn't work
and it's now an undeniable disaster for
democrats
they own it it's their policy they
supported it
and it's also important to note that all
these defund police movements
and officials had no problem using your
tax dollars to hire their own security
services
here with reaction louisiana senator
john kennedy
senator i just handed to you because
this to me is basic
simple louisiana common sense
son i think it is i don't know why this
is sean but
if i make it to heaven i'm going to ask
but there are some
people in this world that just aren't
fit to be part of our society
they're not sick they're not mixed up
they're not confused
it's not a question of whether their
mama or daddy loved them enough
they're they're just anti-social in
terms of public safety they're just bad
and we i thought as a society had agreed
that that's why we need
law enforcement is to get them off the
streets and to protect
law-abiding citizens from them that was
a universal truth
apparently no longer not all but many of
my democratic colleagues have done it
about
faiths um now the the uh the bad guys
are the are the cops
uh i hear it every day the cops are are
guilty until proven innocent and they're
all a bunch of racists apparently even
the african-american police officers
i just don't get it and and president
biden bless his heart
he can run around like a fox on fire and
say not me i never said that i'm not a
part of it
wrong he was he has said it look at the
uh
the democratic platform the written
democratic platform on which he ran
he wrote it they talk about reimagining
the police
and the president has supported every
single one of our major democratic
mayors in every major democratic city
they not only talked about defunding the
police they
did it and what was the result it was
very
predictable crime has gone through
the roof and it can be reversed
but if the president asked me my opinion
he hasn't but if he did i would say mr
president
you need to stand up in front of god and
country and say all this defund the
police stuff
has got to stop and and tell your
your supporters these democratic mayors
to lift the police out don't put them
down
all right senator we always appreciate
you being with us all right stay with us
more hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else